this is a production of Cornell
University
yeah unfortunately you're going to hear
legal stuff at the end of the day I'm
going to try to keep this a little
breezy I mean what you've heard was from
your public officials all sorts of
excitement about the opportunities you
heard actually really fascinating
information from the researchers and the
scientists about what they're doing
really interesting stuff about the
farmers now I can get to talk about
regulations but I don't think of them as
regulations really I think really it's
just creating an environment hopefully a
safe environment given that farm bill
essentially creates carve outs to work
in this area and leaves it to the state
to develop a program either through its
own research program or through
educational institutions to establish
programs which permit the research and
study of this plant and what we're
attempting to do is listen to the folks
who are interested in it listen to the
industry needs and try to form a program
that addresses the needs of Industry to
study and research and create a base
when things hopefully change in
Washington so that this industry can
really launch and grow so that's sort of
what we're up to and it's an iterative
process I mean I've been at the agency
for about four years and I think we're
on our third set of regulations in
industrial hemp which is a lot of
regulatory work what we're currently in
the process of doing now is taking what
we built on and expanding it so that are
essentially private partners have rules
of the game we've adopted program
regulations in connection with the six
sites which were available under our
current law as you've heard we've now
well with with current legislative
session we've essentially eliminated
that tent site limitations so there's a
large opportunity for Pete
who are interested in the area to make
application to the department to engage
in the study and research industrial
hemp and the range of I guess the range
of research is almost as broad as the
number the huge number of applications
for this particular product so while
we're in the AG department we often
think about agronomic research I mean it
goes from agronomic research to you know
setting cultivars growing conditions but
it also involves market research and
production so it's an entire array of
possibilities some of which we are quite
familiar with and some of which we
haven't traditionally been involved in
so it's a learning process on our part
one of the fun things about listening to
all these panelists is a lot of it you
sort of going yeah I learned that but
there's so much more to learn so from
the legal side it's a really exciting
area because it both exposes your
knowledge base and also your profound
ignorance without what can happen so
it's sort of like a lot of fun because
one a lot of the things we see and that
the department has done has been done
over time and it's a building effort and
we're dealing with structures that
already been created this is a new
opportunity it's a new program so you
can form it and mold it and try to make
it work as efficiently as possible which
is both challenging and is an exciting
so it's interesting for me hopefully
it's interesting and useful for you and
I can't emphasize how important it is to
get input from the folks who are there
in the fields doing the research doing
the growing and getting information
because I mean regulations just really
rules of the game so we try to create
certainty and clarity everyone knows
what's going on and you can perform in a
relatively easy environment they cost
what's required is clear and it's it
addresses sort of your needs so saying
all of that i'll give you a breezy intro
duction to what our program currently
looks like and essentially will look
like because it's really it's pretty
simple notwithstanding and the
challenges we're working in a murky
federal environment so you've got
transitioning where you've got
carve-outs under the federal farm bill
you've got additional supplements in
connection with the omnibus budget bill
which expands sort of the range and
scope of these activities but they're
not particularly fleshed out you've got
uncertainty at the federal regulatory
level when you speak to the agencies um
they're sort of tentative in their
approach because it's new to them and
the states are the ones who are really
developing these programs so in some
ways we have lots of opportunity but in
certain sense were also on our own in
trying to develop programs that serve
the needs of the industry and serves the
needs of public and that's sort of what
we're up to so essentially it currently
we've got a research program we're
accepting private partners we also work
with educational institutions but
generally our approach to both of these
entities is pretty much the same you've
got an application process the
application is fairly straightforward
and the information that is required is
fairly directed we obviously as required
by law require disclosure of the sites
we are looking for for research
proposals because ultimately our pilot
project projects our pilot projects for
research and study so when you know Dan
tells us you got to be thoughtful and
you've got a plan that's true in terms
of your approach to this agency as well
because what we're looking for is a
thoughtful plan as to what areas you
would like to work in and develop which
contributes to the knowledge and the
development of this particular industry
but it's research and study based and it
also needs to be appropriately scaled to
the project that you're proposing so I
mean we've had suggestions in our
regulations that agronomic research and
marketing research but but essentially
what you really need to
due to have a successful application is
to think about what you want to research
what areas can be developed and then
make the proposal to the agency and
we're pretty flexible but you need to
develop that it's got to be serious it's
got to be thoughtful and if it is then
chances are you're going to be reviewed
favorably you also need to think about
security issues now security issues from
our experience has been sort of
interesting when we first embarked upon
looking at regulations there was a huge
security concern and we were thinking
that we really needed very structure a
very structured approach to the kind of
security that was necessary for folks
cultivating industrial hemp and as we
learned more about other states
experience and other growers experience
we had a much softer approach and
currently while you need a security plan
the security plan needs to be a sensible
one you need to consider what kind of
access there is to the the plants being
grown or access to the facility and we
don't have any specific requirements but
what you really need to do is assess the
risks that you may have in connection
with security issues and then adopt
appropriate responses to those risks so
it's a more flexible approach it's not a
top-down you've got to fence you're
growing areas you've got to have a
particular kind of signage but it's more
of an iterative process where you think
about what your problems could be and
how do you address them and that sort of
the approach we've taken um I'd also
mention that the scale is important
we're talking about demonstration
projects so that doesn't necessarily
need to be really really tiny but it
needs to be appropriately scaled so what
you're researching is appropriate to the
America going to be cultivating um there
are obviously issues in connection with
what we do in evaluating I mean
basically we will be looking at
background checks
and we will be looking at no past
experience it was sort of interesting in
our discussions with other state
agencies this was an area that people
identified yeah there's a concern here
we had applicants who had all sorts of
issues be at regulatory or otherwise so
you need to be mindful and make sure
that the folks you partner with in
research are responsible individuals and
that's sort of what we're looking for so
you know their requirements for
disclosure and you take a look at that
um we basically requiring our partners
to enter into partnership agreements or
research partner agreements and
basically that's your roadmap you're
going to have a regulatory structure
which gives you sort of like the general
marks you need to hit in connection with
what's expected of you as a research
partner that's dealt with in our
research partner agreement and basically
what that does is a thai buddhist scope
of work so basically you undertake to
conduct a project and we expected to
adhere to that project um it's flexible
enough to modify as you're going on so
that if you want to go into related
areas you can but if it's a separate
research project then you'll have to do
a separate application but there's
flexible it provides for disclosures and
vetting it makes clear that once you get
a permit that it's not transferable
permit it permits subcontracting we have
reporting requirements so I mean
basically if you're involved in a
project will be annual reporting
requirements providing data but at the
same time or research partnership
agreement protects your intellectual
property at which you develop is yours
and we make it clear that it's he was so
that's covered in our agreement we deal
with with testing regimens and
procedures to make sure that it is
indeed when you get it its industrial
have been where you grow it its
industrial hemp um in sit I want one of
the useful things for us in connection
with sitting through this summit we
heard issues with respect to hot seed
and that's something that we probably
need to take a closer look at
because this is a new issue that I don't
know Chris had seen it but it was a new
issue for me and it's something that we
deal with in our partnership agreements
but it's something I think we maybe want
to kick the tires a little better on we
deal with the security so so that that's
sort of the structure of our program it
was the structure of the program before
it's a little bit more formalized now
and that's sort of where we are um one
of the things i would encourage you all
to do because we will be formulating
regulations and there's a lot of public
comment and we look forward to that
comment both during once we publish
regulations we get comment but even now
before they get published give me a call
talk to us if there are issues we need
to focus on you are the best folks to
advise with what those issues are
because you're working in the field hey
I'm just a lawyer but and and I can
create clear regulations i can create
clear rules but basically it's your
knowledge base that helps me get to a
position where everyone knows what's
going on and we can do a program that
works for you because ultimately that's
what our job is to create a clear set of
rules that you can understand and you
can follow and creates a space for you
to operate that won't run into problems
with federal authorities and that's what
I've got to say thank you Scott
[Applause]
so I thank you Scott so I think the one
thing that I would reiterate I don't
have a great deal to add to what Scott
has has talked about this afternoon on
the regulations but I think going
forward one of the things I'd like to
reiterate which Scott brought up is is
the importance of in the application
process and in the regulation the
importance of formulating the research
questions and articulating that in a
clear way to us you know up until now
this has been a this has been a program
where we had a limitation of 10 permits
and there has been the ability to have a
great deal of interaction with
applicants and also the ability to have
us when we get an application and we
have questions to call people and
clarify and I think as this goes forward
based upon the interests that I've seen
here today in the and the number of
phone calls I've had as we go forward
and this becomes a higher volume program
for us if you will it's going to be very
very important that when the research or
when the applications come in to us that
the research questions are well thought
out and I guess one of the things that I
would would throw out there to people as
well as you know Scott and myself and
other staff at AG and markets being
available you know to to help is also
you know the folks who have sort of gone
before whether the morrisville folks who
are the Cornell people or the
Cooperative Extension people out there
who can help you to formulate a good
research question and get a get a strong
proposal in to us you know it takes the
same amount of effort to look at
something that's strong as well written
versus something that that perhaps is
not as strong so I think that's going to
be really important as the volume of the
program increases all right we're going
to entertain one question because we're
running up against the end of our lease
time here in this space but one question
that producers have been asking is
you know and I think it's a valid
question does growing hemp negate the
ability to participate in any other
federal programs give them the federal
rules about growing cannabis an
interesting question I don't practice in
the area so give you a non-legal
response which doesn't find the agency
this is a high opinion there's a lawyer
coming out under the federal farm bill a
car that was created it authorizes these
programs my approach or my thought would
be in that you have a specific federal
carve out it would be inappropriate for
a federal agency to tell you that this
is going to disqualify you from other
available federal programs that's just
my personal analysis of it the federal
agencies may beg to differ but that's
just where I am awesome Chris any less
up alright a round of applause for these
two please
[Applause]
we've had a great day here I think it
was a great morning it was a great
afternoon we've had great panels I think
hopefully you've learned at least as
much as I've come to understand I think
we heard a couple of things to one we
heard the need to go forward in a
collaborative manner the need for state
agencies to have kind of a uniform
protocol and I'm thinking in my case of
Department of Agriculture Department of
Health Department of Justice and are
frankly our funding partners at empire
state development as well I think we
heard about the need for continued
research applied research while
varieties about fertility about
utilizing the rate equipment the right
cultural methods what does this mean for
rotations there's all kinds of questions
that we have which frankly kind of
conjures up in my mind integrated plant
science isn't that what we're talking
about here a little plug for Cornell
there I think we heard a little bit
they're quite a lot about the need for
federal advocacy to help lift that cloud
that we're still operating under adjust
in that last question and I'm going to
borrow a little bit from something that
Dan Dahl gen from JD farm said this
morning I think that I think we need the
correct interaction between all the
state agencies and our partners I think
we need the leadership here at the land
grant system is we've evidence today
quite a lot the leadership from the
industry which i think is certainly
clear to me here from this meeting today
and exemplified in our panels but also
the leadership at the state level which
I think we've clearly demonstrated by
the participation of our lieutenant
governor and by the governor's actions
in this in this new opportunity and you
combine that with a vision and I think
it needs to be a common vision that we
all share and that we stay close to so
that let me just say we're committed to
that thank you for being here thank you
for participation for your energy for
your past
about all this a special thank you to
our legislative partners who have helped
with the legislation to make this
possible and certainly a special thank
you to our host here today at Cornell
for putting up with us all day long and
for their continued partnership so with
that thank you all for attending the
very first M summit in New York State
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu